foreign
[Music]
looks like she hasn't been washed in
years I'll see you later baby it was
nice to meet you I really should find my
way back home any places landmarks you
remember I remember the devil in the sky
look at that guy and Hell mother son of
a dumbest models
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse
that is the craziest thing I have ever
seen and I'm Dennis Quaid and Dennis
Quaid has seen some
starving how many of these should we eat
all of them give me a sec whoa you look
different you look different too how so
is it my human hands
the cops what do we do calm down I got
this hello officer none of us shut the
up Strays in theaters August 18
rated R
[Music]
thank you